beirut is changing rapidly after a
bitter civil war that left behind
countless scars locals and tourists
alike can once again enjoy the city
customers constantly mill in and out of
so have scions snack bar
here falafel is the snack of choice it's
a staple in food joints across the
Middle East this place was established
in maybe 1933 when my grandfather was
the first one who made the falafel
business and Lebanon and then came my
father and now on the third generation
making falafel requires large amounts of
hot oil and chickpeas since the money we
start preparing it so it might take
about three to four hours yeah to
prepare everything the chickpeas are
crushed and seasoned with parsley
coriander garlic spring onions salt
pepper cumin and cayenne pepper then
everything is rolled into little balls
and deep fried until it's crispy
in Beirut falafel is served with fresh
lettuce herbs finely sliced radishes and
tomatoes
and finally territory is added it's a
thick sauce made of yogurt garlic
cucumbers and nuts just fold it over and
it's ready to eat they actually work in
all Lebanese people love this food we
could eat it from morning tonight if it
enough most of the customers here are
manual workers they're people who do
physical labor like the kind of work you
do at construction sites chickpeas give
your body strength and energy ebay
system so if you're feeling sluggish
head to Beirut
you